Jim is in Georgia hi Jim welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey how are you doing
better than I deserve what's up I would
had a question earlier this year
basically in January I was unemployed
and again my job search basically ran up
credit card debt probably the first four
months of 2019 the next three months as
sold aspects etc and the last probably
since about September of this year had
to fall behind on my mortgages with
stayed in contact with them basically do
my garden table I do now yeah I do now
okay and what do you make now well NASA
that's the other side that's going I was
making 140 and now I'm making 70 so
basically half doing one and accounting
you're doing accounting and making 140
yes okay how how is the VP level so with
that level of like determined during my
thirds was well let me back up the first
quarter of this year I was kind of
hanging on to the company to see if
things cuz they were in a bad position
and I was trying to see if things would
turn around and so I started using up
yeah I started incurring credit card you
know and then after I've kind of got
through that I thought it selling off
assets I eventually got a job but I'm at
the point now where I you know basically
I've entered into a loan modification
program with the mortgage lender and I
kind of had a Tenten you come with you
this moment prepared a budget and
basically get it all non-essential
utilities know I had life insurance
policies so basically yes you're hard
utilities that you know there's internet
service
Paulo barrels that type thing and I'm at
a point now where was your house or this
it it says 297 corn estimate okay
problem that's not necessarily accurate
what do you oh yeah right there what are
you oh 261 and how far behind are you
I'm not for months right now okay and
now you're paying a payment and a
quarter or payment in the half to get
current well now I would need I've got
that to get current in order to either
do bankrupt city and or something
magical came along I would need I
thought you had a payment plan worked
out with your mortgage company well I
went to for their yeah that's what I
mean okay and then forbearance I went
through the forbearance and I did not
have a job at the time and I only had
like nine nineteen thousand in the bank
was aboard I was down to so I paid him
like 20 bucks for the forbearance per
month and this we got contacted him and
let him that were actually the blast we
got contacted them and let him know that
I had a job and they said well that's
great let's get you to a loan
modification program and when I'm when
I'm done I've done my budget for
basically just my my car my mortgage
South before other than the mortgage how
much debt do you have and you're out
much do in the car that's 40,000 okay
why do you still have it well I when
going back to June my credit was about
760 in 787 in June and when I started
holding back payments to the credit
cards obviously it took a hit and then
when I went through the forbearance
further and would be mortgage company
okay okay okay so you have 40,000 out on
a car how much credit card debt do you
have twenty-nine twenty-eight thousand
okay and what
yeah you have other than your house your
coloring your credit cards yeah okay in
a chapter seven all unsecured debt
becomes zero all secured debt you turn
in the asset or you agree to bring it
current and pay the payment yes sir and
so if you kept the car and kept the
house in a chapter 7 bankruptcy you
would only be found bankruptcy on
$28,000 or the credit cards which is
ridiculous
right okay in a chapter 13 you pay
payments on everything if you could pay
payments on everything we wouldn't be
having this discussion
so bankruptcy does not do anything for
you the only thing that's going to do
something for you is selling the house
and selling the car which is what you
need to do so with the cars I sell the
car I ran into this earlier was that
okay with my credit which is about 550
now obviously buying a used car and
tacking on $4,000 worth the negative
equity from my current car is going to
basically put me up around $500 came in
a monthly payment listen here's the
thing your problem is is that you're a
little bit too smart with numbers and
you're trying to trick your way through
this there's no trick you need to take
them there's no scalpel gonna work
you're at the stage you need to use a
machete
this is blunt instrument time not
nuanced calculations so you have got to
not have a $40,000 car payment when you
make $70,000 a year it was asinine when
you made a hundred and forty that you
did that
it's it's just triple crazy that you
still even own this car under any
possible scenario so yes you have to
borrow
the money to cover the negative and get
you a $1,000 car and then you can work
your way out of that debt and you sell
your house and you move into an
apartment and you'll get your life back
well what this is the price you're
paying for not working for a year while
you try to screw around with this
company that was broke you got yourself
so far behind you can't catch up dude
right you know how with the house if I
go to an apartment they're gonna run
credit which maybe maybe you can find a
landlord that'll just work with you and
say I'm an accountant I make seventy
thousand dollars a year you know I've
gone through losing some things so I've
got some dings on my credit if you pull
it but I'm in a position now that I can
afford to pay your apartment bill and I
can show you my budget not all
apartments require a high credit score
to rent
listen you rationalize the crap out of
keeping all this stuff if you want but
you're not gonna make it if you keep all
this stuff this stuff is gonna leave
it's gonna leave voluntarily or they're
gonna start taking it because you don't
have the money to pay these bills that's
what you called me about if I'm you I'm
amputating the crap out of some stuff
and get your life back then you can get
your career back in order and start
rebuilding from there sorry man I'm
really sorry you're going through this
but you have got to take some action for
the first time in this whole story